oh [ __ ]  what what  that's a Kitner boy read that so  remember Andy Pitts and if it's a really  yeah no Andy rip its key andy Pizzarelli  was andy blue balls that's it get  married to call him and Pizzarelli  what's your [ __ ] point well they say  he can get into anything anything they  say he's been in Margaret Thatcher's  [ __ ] and that's a good thing so what  the [ __ ] are you getting it when I was  in the joint where they may tell me if  the kinder boy read out can't be cracked  are you [ __ ] me are you telling me  that after I prop you up held you  together smile for all those kids dance  for all those [ __ ] housewives and a  [ __ ] lime green [ __ ] bear without  costume that you cannot get in this  [ __ ] state is that what you telling  me Bob no I'm just saying it's gonna  take a minute  [Music]  you  [Music]